[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 y me acompaña en el estudio
rosa pérez más de euros a felix mañana
de miércoles hoy 20 de julio entonces
abrimos esta revista de prensa con un
repaso a algunos titulares acerca del
nuevo presidente de la ncaa estamos
hablando de running week creeme sing
buenos días raúl exactamente y la
lectura que podemos hacer de los
titulares que hemos visto alrededor del
mundo es precisamente la incertidumbre
sobre cuán estable y duradera puede ser
precisamente esta nueva presidencia de
wii que me sigue dado que los
protestantes consideran una solución de
continuidad respecto a la presidencia de
gotabaya rajapaksa como bien decías en
un primer lugar veamos el salón today
este medio srilanqués que precisamente
lanzaba el breaking news después de que
wii que me sigue fuera elegido con una
amplia mayoría en el parlamento
srilanqués como comentaba en los
noticieros para acabar el término hasta
2024 que dejó vacío rajapaksa por otro
lado el south china morning post'
considera y advierte que los
manifestantes continuarán con las
protestas en medio de la escasez de
alimentos combustible y medicinas
precisamente al yazira señala
exactamente lo mismo los líderes de las
protestas comentan a este medio que
continúan discutiendo una estrategia
para echar a wii chrome singer del poder
concretamente la cita es sabemos que wii
cree messing en no es lo mismo que
rajapaksa es más astuto incluso ha
tratado de reprimir la protesta
imponiendo el estado de emergencia pero
creo que la gente no se deja intimidar
por estas medidas y por último para
terminar con esta ronda las tienen a
titular ante la elección de wii que me
sigue algunos manifestantes prometen
continuar luchando citan el discurso del
nuevo presidente este discurso de unidad
nacional quedado ante el parlamento y
recuerda la sien en la entrevista que
dio precisamente ubique mensing el
pasado lunes a esta misma cadena en la
que quiso desde distanciarse en esta
entrevista de su antecesor de rajapaksa
acusándolo de ocultar datos sobre la
situación financiera del país cuando
todavía se podría ver he hecho algo y
precisamente también ree que me sigue en
esta entrevista de las 100 en del pasado
lunes prometió re estabilizar la
situación económica del país para 2023
en todo caso iremos siguiendo la
situación ante cerca sin duda así es
rosa pasamos ahora la revista alemana
'der spiegel' que esta semana publicó
una entrevista con henry kissinger
conocido secretario de estado de eeuu y
para los presidentes nixon y fuerte
exactamente es una entrevista donde
kissinger a sus 99 años responde al
periodista bernard shaw desde su casa de
connecticut en eeuu y hablan de un
amplio abanico de temas pero si te
parece voy a leer como empieza en esta
entrevista dando un poco de contexto
histórico a esta figura tan polémica y
conocida que ese henry kissinger el
periodista empieza diciendo el señor
kissinger cuando usted nació lenin aún
vivía usted tenía 29 años cuando murió
stalin 39 cuando nikita khrushchev
desplegó misiles nucleares en cuba y 45
cuando bréznev aplastó la primavera de
praga
cuál de estos gobernantes gobernantes
del kremlin le recuerda más vladimir
putin a lo que henry kissinger responde
sin dudarlo aparentemente kruschev dice
khrushchev quería reconocimiento se han
invitado a eeuu el concepto de igualdad
era muy importante para él en el caso de
putin esto es todavía más acentuado
porque considera el colapso de la
posición rusa en europa a partir de 1989
un desastre estratégico para rusia dice
ésta ha sido su obsesión realmente x
singer dice que no comparte la opinión
de muchas personas que piensan que putin
quiere recuperar todo el territorio que
se perdió pero asegura que lo que no
puede soportar el líder del kremlin es
que todo el territorio entre berlín y la
frontera rusa caiga en manos de la otan
y dice y esto es lo que dice de ucrania
un punto clave para él
así es rosa también precisamente que
comenta kissinger sobre la guerra en
ucrania como la cabeza de terminar en
ese segmento
precisamente esta opinión es bien una
controvertida se ha comentado a lo largo
de los meses y insiste en que él no
aboga para que porque ucrania se da
territorio a rusia sino en acordar un
alto al fuego una tregua que respete la
línea de contacto precisamente del 24 de
febrero la que era la frontera antes de
que empezara la guerra con los
respectivos territorios que ya se habían
autoproclamado independiente y por otro
lado hay un punto clave muy destacable
de lo que comenta a kissinger y es un
poco la historia de las últimas décadas
desde que terminó la guerra fría y la
que ha sido la relación entre rusia y
europa y precisamente x singer dice
cuando termine esta guerra la cuestión
será si rusia logra una relación
coherente con europa lo que siempre ha
buscado o si se convierte en un puesto
de avanzada de asia en la frontera de
europa algo digamos a que preferiría
eeuu no respecto a unas relaciones
normalizadas entre rusia y la unión
europea rosa vamos a ver hablar también
de la cuestión de china taiwán a
recordando el viaje de nixon y kissinger
a china hace ya 50 años para reunirse
con mao tse tung exactamente y es que el
periodista le pregunta si considera que
este momento de esta invasión rusa de
ucrania va a desencadenar también una
búsqueda por parte de china de una
solución final ya respecto al tema de
taiwán pero básicamente kissinger
considera que no dice putin obviamente
subestima la resistencia que encontraría
en ucrania los chinos sin embargo usarán
toda su fuerza contra taiwán sólo cuando
consideren que es imposible la solución
pacífica y no creo que hayan llegado a
este punto todavía y además entre otras
cosas porque una guerra en taiwán
llevaría a china y eeuu a un conflicto
directo desde el principio rosa como
siempre gracias por esta revista de
prensa el día de hoy miércoles 20 de
julio mañana con más saludamos a nuestro
primer invitado el día